COMMITTEE OF THURSDAY FEBRUARY
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER. PLEASE
READ ADVISER VIDEO AND AUDIO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEED
HAS BEEN MADE. AND IS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED. MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THERE
HERE THEN AT FLORA GIPSON
KAMLAGER WE HEAR LEVINE
MAIENSCHEIN AFTER YEAR RAMOS.
THE APPROVED VIA PUT OFF YEAR
EVERCORE WE A QUORUM WE HAVE A
AGENDA THERE'S A MOTION IS OUR
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
AGAIN MOVERS SAID ABOUT MR
MATTIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
ONE- MISTER SEARCH REVIEWS CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY HI. COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM FIVE.
SENATE HI FLORA FLORA HI GIPSON
GIPSON HI KAMLAGER KAMLAGER. HI
V. I. LEVINE LEVINE HI
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MATHIS HI RAMOS. THE ABUJA HI
YOU PUT OFF BY PUSHING PASSES.
OKAY MOST OF PASSED AND- THERE
IS NO ITEM SEVEN CORRECT. I
HAVE A LITTLE SOMETHING HERE
THAT TELLS ME THAT OKAY ARE
THEN OF THE MOST IS PASSED I
WILL SIT HERE FOR A MOMENT IN
CASE ANYONE ARRIVES LATE BUT
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
STILL WE I THINK WE MAY. YEAH.
YEAH YEAH MISTER KING ARE WE.
EVERYBODY AROUND THE SCHOOL NOW
CRUISER JOHN. YEAH.